and Horizon zero Dawn remake the PS5 has
been jailbroken and Sony plans to make a
bunch of psvr twos all this on today's
Gamespot news
Verizon zero Dawn could be getting a
significant upgrade as a new report
claims that quote accessibility features
Graphics modes and quality of life
improvements to the gameplay itself will
bring Gorilla Games 2017 title up to the
same similar standard as its 2020 sequel
Horizon forbidden West several of these
upgrades can be found in the PC version
of horizon zero Dawn that was released
in 2020 although that game mostly reused
the same assets as the PS4 edition
according to the report Guerrilla games
is also currently working on a horizon
multiplayer game for PS5 and PC Co-op
features had been planned for zero Dawn
as far back as 2014 according to vgc's
sources but these elements were scrapped
so that other areas of the game could be
focused on the idea hasn't been entirely
scrapped for the mainline series and
could make its way into Horizon 3. Sony
is also expanding the series into other
forms of media and with the Horizon TV
show headed to Netflix it wouldn't be
too surprising to see some sort of
announcement from the gaming side of the
series this could be a similar situation
to The Last of Us Part 1 which arrived
ahead of the HBO Max live action Series
in some more PS5 news it looks like
someone has managed to crack the
security on the system the jailbreak was
spotted by Mata Lance McDonald and
uploaded the jailbreak footage to
Twitter showcasing how the software can
give a user access to the ps5's debug
menu additionally A PS5 with the
software installed can also have game
backups installed on it with McDonald's
footage showing the delisted PT demo
being loaded onto the system although it
wasn't playable on the system the
exploit does come with numerous
limitations though as its makers claim
that it only works around 30 percent of
the time and has multiple potential
points of failure the exploit will only
work on consoles with foam firmware
version 4.03 from October 2021 and it is
possible that ps5s with earlier firmware
could run it according to the Creator
the software in its current state won't
be too useful to the ordinary gamer as
the creator of the exploit noted that
hackers and people who are curious to
see what's under the hood of the PS5
will find it worth installing in even
more PS5 news Sony reportedly plans to
have 2 million units of the psvr 2
headset ready by March next year mass
production of the virtual reality
headset reportedly began in September
and has not yet faced any supply chain
constraints with the PS5 continuing to
be in high demand due to its limited
availability since it launched in
November 2020 Sony also plans to have
more console stock on shelves in early
2023 according to Bloomberg's sources
psvr2 has yet to receive a date Beyond
2023 but Sony is attempting to ensure
that there's adequate stock of PS5
console available to play games on the
new headset the hardware will only work
on PS5 and won't be backwards compatible
with psvr Games quote psvr2 feels poised
to be a shot in the arm for it in the
gaming space to more Hussein wrote in
gamespot's psvr2 preview he continues it
remains to be seen whether psvr2 will
Garner widespread interest but at the
very least I'm more confident that it'll
take us one step closer to realizing its
full potential and that is it for
today's Gamespot news what do you think
about the reported remake of horizon
zero Dawn are you going to pick up one
of those 2 million psvr 2 units next
year let us know in the comments below
and we'll see you here tomorrow for more
Gamespot news
[Music]